all right it's time for drew's news your
comfy oversized good news sweater and
with me at the desk my main thread ross
matthews yes hi
[Applause]
everybody love this outfit yeah i took a
risk today pat it on pattern but it's
design week hello
right you're giving me all the feels and
we're both in vest yeah we are best
dressed we are better yeah and i am
invested in our looks today oh invested
come on come on i know god that was good
you are the king of puns and you just
warm the cockles of my heart when you do
it oh thanks and i'm really excited
because
beyond design week it is international
women's day
today is a day to celebrate women all
around the world that have achieved that
often totally against the odds you know
accolades and it's also a day to focus
on how we can break down all the biases
around us and even get closer to gender
equality and people magazine is doing
just that celebrating with their special
women changing the world issue check out
our cover girl lizzo yes lizzy
herself
there was no lizzo that's true the
grammy-winning rapper singer actor and
total charm machine says she blazed her
own path with one goal in mind showing
the world that this is what success can
look like and she wants to embrace and
empower women all over the world who
identify with her who might not think
they fit in the mold and she's gonna
blast right through that mold yes she is
she's so awesome it's so awesome and she
liza just proves this if you don't fit
the mold to break the mold make your own
mold right right yes
and so
many women do that you know and this
issue celebrates game changes across
every field like emily penn who's an
ocean activist who started expedition in
all women's sailing research team that
fights ocean pollution and monica
johnson in louisiana heard non-profit
heroes offers medical care counseling
and professional training to hiv
positive members of our community so
there are women
all over this country making such a
difference i'm such a people magazine
fan i subscribe to it i get it every
week and i want to thank them for
shining the spotlight on these amazing
women because this issue is on
newsstands now and it actually leads me
to a pic from drew's little yellow book
which is my personal curation
but this is something very personal to
me um
this is good night stories for rebel
girls and i'm reading this with my
daughters right now there's actually two
volumes and they're just great
historical
confirmations that there's nothing women
can't do hey
how about that
[Music]